we have a continuing series guys that we
want to break into it's called
ideas that matter with ted and we're
looking at how communities
are debating the best way to reform
police departments
we want to highlight one data-driven
initiative that is already
seeing real results philip
atiba philip attibuck golf
is at the center of the is the ceo and
the co-founder of the center for
policing equity
the center partners with law enforcement
to address bias in policing
in his 2019 ted talk goff said change
starts with rethinking how we think
about racism when we change the
definition of racism
from attitudes to behaviors we transform
that problem from impossible
to solvable because you can measure
behaviors
and when you can measure a problem you
can tap into one of the only universal
rules of organizational success you got
a problem or a goal
you measure it you hold yourself
accountable to that metric so if
every other organization measures
success this way why can't we do that in
policing
police departments he's worked with have
seen a 25 percent
drop in arrest and a 26
decrease in use of force incidents
phillips ativa
goff joins us now good to see you
phillip good morning
good morning vlad all right so let's
get into this uh you say we have to
change the definition
of racism from attitudes to behaviors
explain that yeah so
the most common definition that people
have of racism
is that it's somehow inside of us it's
our contaminated hearts and our
contaminated minds
and while that's really appealing as a
as a messaging tool
it's actually not how the science of
discrimination works it turns out that
if you want people to stop engaging in
biased
behaviors you should change the
behaviors just
directly and when you do that the
conversation about racism
is much less about our character the
thing that people get really defensive
about and it's more about the things we
can actually do
and when you work in policing it's a
pretty good idea to turn down that
temperature
um in the room so that people are less
defensive and you say here's a path
go ahead and take it and if you take it
everybody's better off
that that solution that that change in
definition it isn't just more
scientifically accurate
it does like i said before it changes
the problem from something that's about
who i
am to what i can do
but philip what if if somebody sees me
as less than human if somebody sees me
as less than equal or if they believe
that they are
superior to me wouldn't that inform
their behavior wouldn't that inform how
they treat me
yeah it absolutely does it's not that
prejudice doesn't matter it's not that
discrimination
doesn't matter i've done lots of
research on dehumanization in particular
it's just that it matters a lot less
than we think right so i use this when i
when i teach in class um
if you ever think about somebody who you
think of as a liar right
do they lie with every word that comes
out of their mouth probably not
they probably lie when most people lie
which is what they're motivated to
they think they can get away with it or
they think the punishment's going to be
slight
now turn that around who else would lie
when they're motivated to they think
they can get away with it or the
punishment is going to be slayed
that's the group of people known as
pretty much everybody so situations
are far more powerful than attitudes in
predicting behaviors
and when we focus on situations and the
behaviors themselves
it's easier to make the change and it's
in fact easier to change
attitudes when you change behaviors than
the other way around
right it seems complicated but when you
just say i want the behaviors to stop
and you get them to stop you start
seeing a better world
and honestly people's attitudes will
follow
so when you're working with police
departments uh give us an example
of this idea in action what do you tell
them
sure so we start with the data um so i
give an example uh in las vegas uh the
sheriff at the time it's a police
department that has a sheriff
um said hey we're concerned we might be
using force too often
the community was very concerned they
were up in arms and asking the justice
department come
and investigate um so we went and we
said all right why
and where it turns out it was after
their foot pursuit that was
disproportional
in terms of their use of force so why
would that be why would foot pursuits be
disproportionately using force well it
turns out if you're an officer
and you're chasing after somebody your
adrenaline's up your heart is pumping
you're sure that person's a bad guy
because who runs from the cops
bad guys that means even if they
surrender and say please don't hurt me
they might be getting a shot to the
kidneys for the price of making me run
so as soon as we gave that back to the
police department in the community they
said
well we know how to do something about
that let's change the training so that
they have to count to ten
they can't touch the person until
someone shows up they're basically just
de-escalating
before they go hands-on with somebody
and in the year following
they reduce their use of force across
the board by 23
these are the kinds of insights that
data can produce when you mix it with
analytics
and behavioral science start here and
you can start at least
gradually bringing down the problem area
because you're holding yourself
accountable to it
so philip you also in 2015 you started
working with the minneapolis police
department you did help them reduce
police use of force but of course we are
now living in the moment
where we have seen police officers in
minneapolis uh
kill george floyd and of course that has
sparked the moment that we are all
living in right now a lot of people
will wonder and say well did it not
stick what happened
yeah so i think the answer to that is
the same answer that i have for people
looking at democracy
sometimes when you're looking and
working on something that really matters
you wake up
every day knowing you're going to fail
at least a little bit
so in minneapolis we were really proud
of the work that we we did
we were proud to bring down use of force
by about 18
over the course of three years and we
also knew there were pockets of the
culture
that were just sitting waiting it all
out they said this chief most chiefs in
major cities only have their job
for about two and a half years i don't
like it i don't want to participate in
the training if i show up
i'm not going to listen i don't care
about the policies
we know that that can happen anyplace
and just like democracy
lots of times we get setbacks on the way
to getting there so it was a gut punch
um i feel for the people who live there
the organizer the activists who it's our
job to empower
who've been working on this for their
entire lives much longer than the three
years that we were there
it's heartbreaking and also it doesn't
mean you got to throw it all out
it does mean though we have to go much
much bigger if we're going to meet this
moment
this can't just be about reforms that
are incremental
it has to be a wholesale reevaluation
about the way we deliver public safety
and if minneapolis has taught us
anything
it shows us that while reforms can work
they're never enough because policing
exists within the broader context and
that broader context desperately needs
change that's why we've seen people
out in the streets for 70 days straight
since
really interesting uh philip attibagoff
thank you as always we appreciate it
thanks so much